en este vídeo quiero dar una
introducción muy breve a dos conceptos a
perímetro y área
voy a poner perímetro aquí a la
izquierda perímetro y voy a poner área a
la derecha
seguramente son conceptos que conoces
pero bueno aquí vamos a dar un breve
repaso vale bueno empecemos con
perímetro el perímetro básicamente es la
distancia alrededor de algo otra forma
de pensarlo es como la longitud que debe
tener una cerca para rodear un objeto o
bien cuánto tendríamos que recorrer para
caminar alrededor de la figura vale
vamos a hacer un ejemplo con un
rectángulo un rectángulo es una figura
de cuatro lados que tiene cuatro ángulos
rectos vale déjame marcar aquí los
cuatro ángulos rectos uno dos tres
cuatro ángulos rectos y sabemos que en
un rectángulo los lados opuestos miden
lo mismo entonces este lado de acá mide
lo mismo que este lado y este lado de
acá mide lo mismo que este lado bueno
entonces déjame marcar los vértices como
b b c y d y pensemos que queremos
calcular el perímetro sabiendo que a b
es igual a 7 le voy a poner que aquí
mide 7 a b es igual a 7 y que bc es
igual a 5 bs es igual a 5 muy bien
entonces pensemos pues si esto fuera un
terreno cuantas cerca tendríamos que
poner alrededor bueno pues tendríamos
que poner cerca aquí aquí aquí y acá
entonces para obtener el perímetro
tenemos que sumar las longitudes de los
cuatro lados vale déjame poner eso por
aquí abajito en algún lado entonces si
queremos obtener el perímetro el
perímetro
perímetro d
b c d entonces tenemos que sumar los
cuatro lados bueno entonces tendríamos
que hacer este 7 + este 5 más la
longitud de la 12 d pero como es un
rectángulo mide lo mismo que la de ave
que es 77 57 y finalmente hay que sumar
la longitud del lado de que también mide
5 vale más 5 y así el perímetro de abc
de sería 75 que es 12 + 7 que es 19 más
5 que es igual a que es igual a 24 muy
bien también podemos hacer las cosas al
revés
a veces conociendo el perímetro podemos
conocer el lado de una figura sobre todo
si esa figura es más o menos especial
por ejemplo si es un cuadrado entonces
vamos a hacer un ejemplo de eso voy a
poner aquí un cuadrado vale un cuadrado
es una figura que tiene cuatro lados
iguales y cuatro ángulos rectos entonces
aquí tendríamos cuatro ángulos rectos
cuatro lados iguales imaginemos que los
lados se llaman pues otra vez
b
c
d
todos los lados son iguales esto es
igual a este que es igual este y que es
igual a este y no sé imagínate que nos
dicen que el perímetro de este cuadrado
el perímetro del perímetro es igual a 36
vale como le haríamos para determinar
cuánto mide cada lado del cuadrado bueno
pues ahora podemos calcular el perímetro
de dos formas distintas déjame llamarle
a este lado x voy a ponerle aquí x
entonces todos los lados miden x éste
mide x éste mide x y esta altura también
mide x de esta forma el perímetro el
perímetro por un lado es 36 entonces 36
36 es igual a el perímetro que es ekis
ekis ekis ekis ekis ekis ekis ekis
y esto de aquí es igual a 4x vale de
esta forma 4x es igual a 36 y bueno es
fácil encontrar un número que al
multiplicarse por cuatro nos da 36 pero
bueno también podemos resolver la
ecuación dividiendo a ambos lados entre
4 entre 4 y con eso nos queda que x es
igual a 36 entre 4 o sea que x es igual
a 9 entonces la longitud del cuadrado es
9 bueno esto es con respecto al
perímetro vamos a practicar ahora un
poquito de área vale entonces el área lo
podemos pensar como cuánto espacio ocupa
una figura en dos dimensiones otra forma
de verlo es no sé imagínate que tenemos
un cuadrado del lado uno tenemos un
cuadrado del lado uno lo bueno de los
cuadrados es que basta decir uno de sus
lados para saber cuál cuadrado es verdad
los rectángulos necesitan las dos
dimensiones necesitamos decir que es un
rectángulo de 7 x 5 pero bueno los
cuadrados con nada más un lado podemos
decirlo aunque bueno a veces podemos
decir el cuadrado de uno por uno vale
eso es lo mismo que el cuadrado del lado
uno
bueno regresando a área podemos pensar
el área como cuántos cuadrados del lado
1 caben en la figura déjame darte un
ejemplo vamos a hacer un ejemplo con
este mismo rectángulo que pintamos aquí
imagínate que queremos determinar ahora
el área de abc de el área la voy a
denotar así con corchetes a b c d vale
entonces para determinar el área hay que
ver cuántos cuadrados de uno por uno
caben aquí y los vamos a acomodar en
filas y en columnas entonces déjame ver
si me queda esto bien lo que tendríamos
que hacer es dividir este rectángulo
aquí en siete columnas
a ver si me queda dice una 2
456 y está seca 7 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 vale y
ahora voy a dividir en filas en cinco
filas entonces me quedaría algo así como
1 2
es 34 muy bien
imagínate que estos en estas cosas feas
que parecen rectángulos en realidad son
cuadrados vale que el dibujo si es
proporcional bueno entonces aquí nos
queda todo dividido en cuadraditos de
uno por uno
cuadraditos del lado uno entonces
tendríamos que ver cuántos de esos hay
aquí podríamos contarlos verdad uno dos
tres pero eso sería muy cansado mejor
pues veamos que son siete columnas y
cada columna tiene cinco cuadraditos
entonces caben 35 cuadraditos verdad ese
35 salió de 7 por 5 y por lo tanto el
área de abs d es igual a 35 entonces ahí
podemos encontrar una regla general
verdad si tenemos un rectángulo un
rectángulo de dimensiones a ive entonces
para determinar el área podemos
multiplicar a por b vamos a hacer otro
ejemplo aquí abajito en color naranja
entonces no sé imagínate que tenemos
aquí 1
un rectángulo de altura un medio y del
lado 2 entonces pues multiplicando un
medio con 2 nos queda que el área es
igual a 1 pero como podemos pensar para
que quepan los cuadraditos de uno por
uno porque parecería que no cabe ninguno
por la altura bueno podríamos pensar que
de este lado ocupó medio cuadradito aquí
hay medio cuadradito aquí estaría la
otra mitad verdad aquí sería un medio
con un medio es uno y aquí sería uno y
aquí podemos poner otro medio cuadradito
vale o sea que hay un medio cuadradito
otro medio cuadradito y entre los dos se
juntan un cuadradito y por eso es la
cantidad de cuadraditos de uno por uno
que caben aquí muy bien
finalmente déjame platicarte acerca del
área de un cuadrado en el caso de un
cuadrado pues hacemos lo mismo que con
los rectángulos verdad porque porque un
cuadrado pues es un rectángulo pero con
sus lados iguales entonces en el caso de
un cuadrado aquí tendríamos ángulos
rectos ángulos rectos ángulos rectos y
no sé imagínate qué
que este se llama w este x este y este z
y sabemos que este lado mide 2 como le
haríamos para determinar el área de v w
x y z como lo haríamos bueno pues es
exactamente la misma idea tenemos que
multiplicar el largo por el ancho sólo
que ahora como aquí tenemos un cuadrado
pues el largo y el ancho son el mismo y
de hecho son iguales a 2 y por lo tanto
nos quedaría que el área es igual a 2
por 2 o bien otra forma de pensar los
cómodos al cuadrado de aquí viene el
nombre de elevar al cuadrado vale de
obtener el área de un cuadrado y en este
caso nos quedaría 2 al cuadrado que es
igual a 4 y finalmente aquí en este
cuadrado también podemos pensar el en el
área como la cantidad de cuadrados del
lado 1 que caben cómo le hacemos
simplemente dividimos aquí a la mitad
aquí a la mitad y como cada lado mide 2
estos de aquí son cuadrados de uno por
uno
y listo con esto dividimos en cuatro
cuadrados del lado uno nuestro cuadrado
del lado 2